well it's important Sam to note that the
orcas partnership they're announcing
today is not about any one particular
country so that's really important for
people to recognize but more broadly
about China I think it's just clear that
it represents a systemic challenge to us
and the world order it's a country with
fundamentally different values to ours
and Its Behavior over the past few years
has been concerning more authoritarian
at home more assertive overseas and we
are aligned with our allies the US
Australia and others in how we perceive
China and in that light it's right that
we do what is necessary to stand up for
our values and to keep us safe for
example recently we blocked investment
in a sensitive sector of our economy and
semiconductors that's an example of the
things that we will need to do and I'll
always do what's required to keep us
safe but this is about the UK and the US
helping Australia which is on the
Pacific on the doorstep of having to
deal with the challenges of China you've
got claim this isn't about the rising
threat of China now it's not about any
one particular Country and this
partnership represents something much
better bigger in fact you know this is
almost an unprecedented multilateral
defense partnership between three allies
who share the same values and what we're
building is the next generation of
attack submarines where there'll be
World beating technology that we will be
able to share with each other and learn
from each other on and those submarines
will be interoperable not just in the
Pacific but in the Atlantic and around
the world and that will help improve our
collective security whilst creating
thousands of jobs as well how does it
make sense turning to the integrated
review how does it make sense to invest
in submarines when there are some that
say that the Army is broken and we are
at war in Europe we're taking a step
back let's look at defense spending in
the round as Chancellor I announced the
largest uplift to defense spending since
the end of the Cold War since then we've
added to that every year five billion
pounds more funding announced today to
support our fantastic Armed Forces with
an ambition to go even higher over time
why are we doing that we're doing it
because the world has become more
volatile the threats to our security
have increased and and it's right that
we as a government me as prime minister
invest appropriately to keep us safe so
that's what we're doing but ultimately
how we spend that money is is something
that our military Chiefs they're the
experts about figuring out what the
right capabilities are to keep us safe
but the main message is more money for
our Armed Forces because the world has
become more dangerous and we need to do
more to keep ourselves safe and that's
what we're doing now you're here in
California there's a hell of a lot going
on back in London a near Bank collapse
the BBC's been a meltdown and then
there's the misery of strikes now
clearly the lesson of this weekend is
when your government wants to do
something quickly as it did with Silicon
Valley Bank it can pull out all the
stops and solve problems but we've had
the misery of strikes for months why
hasn't your government still got a grip
on that well I'm grateful to the unions
that have come in to have dialogue with
the government and we've we've our
message throughout has always been
consistent we've wanted to find our way
through this to resolve industrial
action but we we need to do that on
terms which are fair which are
responsible as we want to bring down
inflation and that are affordable for
the taxpayer now you know with having
good constructive dialogue I don't want
to preempt that but I am grateful to
those unions that are in and having
those conversations we've seen progress
on the rail side we're making progress
with nurses and other healthcare workers
you know I'm disappointed to see the
action by Junior doctors you know I
would urge them and the teachers to come
in and have talks with the government in
the way that other unions are done and
I'm confident that we can find a way
through this you've got a budget this
week you could just put more money in in
order to raise the salaries of key
workers do some people look at you and
wonder if you were experiencing the
misery of many you know of millions you
know having kids staying at home because
of teacher striking unable to get into
work because of the rail strikes maybe
you take this issue and go a bit further
with the amount of money you're prepared
to spend well I you know I don't think
it's right that there's so much
disruption being caused to Working
Families lives that's why AI as prime
minister introduce new laws to have
minimum safety levels in our critical
Public Services like rail like education
like healthcare it's precisely because I
do think people should not be able to
have that disruption impact their lives
that I've putting that new law through
Parliament and with look the biggest
thing on people's minds at the moment is
the cost of living and in me as prime
minister as Toronto they've got someone
who put a new windfall tax on the energy
companies use that money to help reduce
their energy bills by a thousand pounds
because I know that that was a priority
it demonstrated to people that I'm on
their side what's my number one priority
out of my five to halve inflation ease
the burden on the cost of living and
that's what we're going to deliver so in
that budget this week the chancellor in
his Autumn statement was criticized for
not having enough of a vision for growth
um can you confirm that come the time of
the next election Jeremy Hunt will still
be Chancellor yeah of course you know
what at the beginning of the year I set
out three economic priorities out of my
five for the countries to Harvard play
Nation to grow the economy and to reduce
debt and the budget will deliver on all
of those things right we want to keep
bringing the cost of living down for
people we're on track to do that's what
we've got to stick to the plans that's
why it's important that we get public
sector pay settlements right it's more
important that we reduce debt make sure
that we're not passing on burdens to the
Next Generation that also helps us
combat inflation and keeps interest
rates low and you know we've seen some
of the damage that higher interest rates
are causing in particular banks at the
moment and we want to grow the economy
because that's the best way to provide
jobs for people around the country
that's what the chancellor is going to
deliver on Wednesday that's what this
government is going to deliver and
people should feel confident that we've
already brought about enormous
improvements since you know I took over
at the end of last year finally prime
minister you were very quick in the
Autumn to condemn Matt Hancock when he
went on a TV program the other side of
the world and earned lots of money for
it I just wonder whether you have uh any
discomfort about the extraordinary
outside earnings of Boris Johnson he
made 3.7 million pounds in just six
weeks do you feel uncomfortable with the
amount of money he's making the amount
of work he's doing outside of parliament
or is he just too big a political figure
to criticize no I mean ultimately these
are these are going to be decisions that
individual MPS make there's there's lots
of different ways that MPS combine what
they're doing in Parliament and the
other and the other things that they
pursue it's right that there's balance
and that is right that they're able to
represent their constituents you know
there's a set of guidelines in process
in place for this that come from
Parliament itself not not from
government and it's right that they are
a deal why do you not why do you
criticize Matt Hancock but not I think
there's a difference between physically
unable to fulfill your job in in the UK
If you're a raw for a long period of
time and and being able to do other
things alongside I think most people
appreciate there is a difference there
but like I'm not it's not about
individual people you know my general
viewers I've always said is that MP's
primary responsibility should be to
serve their constituents you know that
that is what they are elected to do and
their constituents are wherever they are
whichever policy they're from will
always hold them accountable for doing
that